vou contar pra vocês uma história que
aconteceu comigo há dois dias foram 27
horas para conseguir chegar a joinville
14 horas até são paulo 12 horas de
espera em são paulo uma hora de são
paulo joinville
quando cheguei no hotel tudo que eu
queria era a primeira bala perdida
precisava tomar um banho cair na cama
para que eu abro minha mala e tudo
roubado tinha sido assaltada
ela tinha sido aberta e tem chance de
furtados e lá estava eu querendo dormir
tempo tendo que resolver a situação da
minha mala roupas e até de susto e olha
para trás estou tudo que eu preciso ver
se o padre está aqui dentro a roupa do
tédio na lente de contato
depois da segunda reação de frustração
não somente uma razão de frustração o
que eu tenho que comprar vários daqueles
itens de novo
foi uma frustração porque aquelas
pessoas a quem eu confiei a minha mala
as pessoas que não cuidaram do meu bem
estar muito pelo contrário
naquele momento a minha confiança
a empresa aérea tinha sido quebrada e aí
eu pensei nunca mais vou viajar por essa
empresa aérea
e aí eu também tenho um passo para trás
e pensei eu preciso continuar viajando e
vão ter momentos que eu posso ter que
continuar usando essa empresa aérea
então é melhor eu entrar em contato com
eles que tomar parte da confiança e ver
o que pode ser resolvido
e aí eu passei para pensar como quem
astro estava tão relacionado apesar da
apresentação deu certo e como que
confiança é tão central na base de todos
os relacionamentos que a gente tem com
os nossos pais nossos amigos da escola
que a gente escolhe estudar o hospital
que a gente decide quando a gente fica
doente sal que a gente decidir
e porque não dizê lo do poder
quantos de nós desconfiamos do governo e
aí pergunta mais da mental
o que nós fazemos para que a nossa
desconfiança contribua para a melhoria
do governo e para a melhoria das
democracias confiança nos governos
alcançou níveis baixos na última década
em alguns casos níveis baixíssimos
esse não é um diagnóstico válido apenas
para o brasil argentina méxico e rússia
há pesquisas que mostram que não chega a
50% a confiança dos cidadãos os governos
americano inglês francês espanhol ou
indonésio e uma série de outros do v
para se ter uma noção 1 em 2012
a organização para cooperação e
desenvolvimento econômico
antigamente conhecida como clube dos
países ricos constatou que em média
apenas 40% dos cidadãos dos seus países
membros
confiava no governo do brasil confiança
no governo trata a desconfiança nos
governos ultrapassa a 65%
em geral esses números são muito
preocupantes
primeiro porque confiança é central para
o sucesso de uma série de políticas
públicas em especial inclusive políticas
e econômicas
mas mais que isso porque confiança
determina como nossos cidadãos
decidimos relacionar com o governo
quando eu tenho 100% de confiança no
governo
eu estou disposta a interagir com
estrutura governamental e com a
estrutura política para melhorar a
entrega de políticas públicas o primeiro
para melhorar o sistema político
por outro lado quando a confiança é zero
não tem confiança nenhuma pode faltar
incentivo para qualquer tipo de
participação política pode faltar
incentivo até mesmo pra gente votar pois
bem eu não vim aqui só das más notícias
é urgente da parte das boas notícias
mesmo nesse cenário aparentemente
negativo há pelo menos duas positivas
a primeira delas aqui
apesar de toda a sociedade precisa de um
nível mínimo de confiança para se
desenvolver a democracia podem se
beneficiar de algum nível de
desconfiança caso nós cidadãos
consigamos converter a nossa
desconfiança política organização de
onde então vem a segunda boa notícia é
um dos principais instrumentos para
nossa organização se fica cada vez mais
a nossa posição e de forma cada vez mais
simples e mais fácil eu estou me
referindo à informação pública
mais de 100 países ao redor do mundo
entre eles o brasil adotaram leis que
permitem aos cidadãos e acesso a
informações públicas
e mais que isso a maior parte de nós
hoje anda com dedos na mão
cada foto que a gente possa publicamente
o desenvolvimento de uma obra pública da
condição de um hospital de uma merenda
escolar
são dados que a gente está gerando mas
pra que a gente possa fazer com que
esses dados melhor em nosso governo e
melhorem a estrutura eo funcionamento
das nossas democracias é preciso mais
que simplesmente aumentar a pasta de
dados a nossa posição é importante a
gente precisa criar verdadeiras
políticas de transparência
a gente precisa com que estes dados
estejam organizados organizado numa
linguagem simples e organizada numa
linguagem inclusiva por um pequeno
exemplo pra você
é como se hoje a gente deixar de
discutir o ajuste fiscal do governo
federal e de diversos países ao redor do
mundo simplesmente em termos de bilhões
de reais bilhões de dólares e passados a
conversar em termos do desemprego que
são perdidos de quem perdem seus
empregos às pequenas e médias empresas
foram fechadas de tipo de pequenas e
médias empresas são fechadas
a gente passa a discutir quem são os
verdadeiros perdedores pesados
é por isso que transparência e acesso à
informação é tão importante porque eles
nos dão condições de sentar à mesa
e debater com os nossos representantes e
discutir políticas públicas de igual a
igual transparência e acesso à
informação nos dão condições de
realmente participar do governo
eu vou ser um pouquinho mais
transparente também vou mostrar pra
vocês
imagem um pouquinho do que estou falando
esses são dados disponibilizados pelo
senado federal são dados do orçamento da
união
esse é apenas um órgão do governo
federal quanto de nós consegue ler esses
dados mas algumas pessoas que conseguem
ler esses dados da fundação getúlio
vargas criaram uma iniciativa chamada
mosaico orçamentário em que aqui a gente
pode falar onde está dedicada a maior
parte do orçamento federal
quem gasta mais o orçamento federal onde
esse gasto vai quanto é orçado e quando
de fato é gasto o próprio governo
federal criou uma iniciativa que o
portal da transparência onde dados
financeiros execução financeira do
governo federal são disponibilizados
porque aqueles dados foram
disponibilizadas numa linguagem simples
vários jornais conseguiram criar notícia
em cima do portal da transparência do
portal da transparência foi não apenas
fonte dessas notícias mas essas notícias
levaram à investigação de uma série de
casos de responsabilização de agentes
públicos e melhor ao aprimoramento da
legislação federal sobre a execução
financeira
o último exemplo eu vou dar pra vocês
como de dados públicos são resultado do
tribunal superior eleitoral sobre
financiamento de campanha
os dados estão todos disponíveis na
página do tse da leitura realmente é
bastante complicada
em 2014 a equipe de tecnologia do
projeto brasil criou um plug in para
google chromium 20 quando a gente
estivesse lendo uma notícia de jornal ea
gente passasse o mouse em cima do nome
de um de um candidato à presidência
apareciam ele quem eram os financiadores
daquela daquela campanha
e há também aquelas experiências que são
realizadas com dados produzidos pela
própria sociedade
um desses exemplos é o diário de classe
disponibilizado no facebook
basicamente o que ele é
é a transparência são fotos geradas por
uma garota de 12 anos que queria
disponibilizar informar como era um
mulherão as condições da escola dela
basicamente o que adoro fazer começou a
fazer por disponibilizar fotos de
merenda escolar das condições da escola
dela as condições de estrutura falta dos
professores e exceto o que acontece
nesse caso é muito interessante
todos nós cidadãos normais sabemos o que
a gente espera do funcionamento de uma
escola pública
portanto o que aconteceu foi que a
partir do momento que adora fab
disponibilizou realizados ela conseguiu
gerar mobilização social em torno
daqueles dados e depois disso o que
houve é que os governos responderam a
estrutura política respondeu às demandas
daquela garota e é por isso que nem
sempre transparência trivial porque
transparência não é simplesmente a
organização dos dados a sua publicação e
sua divulgação se a gente não conseguir
mobilizar pessoas em torno de dados
públicos transparência pública pode ter
sido uma oportunidade perdida por outro
lado quando a gente consegue mobilização
em torno de dados
o governo responde a estrutura política
responde e é por isso que a gente tem
que passar a se organizar em torno dos
principais problemas da nossa democracia
mas eu mostrei pra vocês do estado do
tribunal do tribunal superior eleitoral
mostra também o plugin desenvolvido pela
equipe do projeto brasil
pois bem aqueles dados só tem muito
sentido porque no brasil como vocês vêem
nessa figura dos candidatos eleitos os
candidatos eleitos em campo têm
campanhas 12 vezes maiores do que os
candidatos não eleitos
isso indica que antes de a gente votar
existe uma pré eleição o valor das
campanhas aumentando cada dia mais a
cada eleição a capacitação campanha do
brasil ficam cada vez mais caro e muitas
vezes a gente tem uma mesma empresa
lanciano candidato à esquerda um
candidato ao centro e o candidato à
direita
a gente pergunta por que porque há
momentos em que vale a pena e é por isso
que a gente precisa dar transparência a
esses dados porque muitas vezes a
relação dessas empresas com o governo
pode estar valendo mais que o nosso voto
e pode está valendo mais do que a nossa
participação
a gente quer transparência para poder
aumentar a nossa voz dentro do governo
a gente precisa eliminar tudo aquilo
todos os mecanismos que não são não tem
base unicamente cidadã
foi pensando nisso que ano passado um
grupo de amigos e eu criamos um projeto
para dar transparência às propostas dos
candidatos tinham traz áreas de educação
saúde segurança pública meio ambiente
a gente decidiu criar um projeto em
torno do período eleitoral por três
motivos primeiro motivo porque a gente
sabia que no período eleitoral o cidadão
já estão buscando informa informação
estão abertos ao debate
segundo porque a gente queria resgatar o
valor do voto o voto não é um mecanismo
central democracias representativas
contemporâneas simplesmente ao acaso
o voto tem um mecanismo de igualdade
mesmo no brasil
o voto é um voto rico ou pobre um negro
o branco o do homem e da mulher
em terceiro lugar porque a gente achava
que apesar de todas as propostas dos
candidatos para televisão estaremos site
do zero seus respectivos partidos
muitas vezes essas propostas não eram
comparáveis à comparabilidade das
propostas é muito baixa pois bem nós
pegamos todas aquelas propostas
organizamos no nosso site de forma tão
simples que para algumas pessoas nosso
site bombar ia de acesso imediatamente
mas não é o que acontece é que mesmo
durante o período eleitoral em que nós
cidadãos estamos engajados e dispostos
ao debate público
muitas vezes a gente não quer abrir mão
de algumas premissas por exemplo
a premissa de que o meu candidato tem a
melhor proposta para a educação melhor
proposta para a área de saúde da área de
meio ambiente segurança pública
quando a gente esperava esse resultado a
gente conhecia esse aspecto do
comportamento humano e ele tinha se
preparado
o que a gente fez na seqüência foi criar
jogos em que primeiro as pessoas
tivessem que conhecer a proposta e
apenas depois que elas conhecessem as
propostas elas passaram a conhecer quem
era o candidato menos de dois meses nós
conseguimos que as propostas do
candidato os candidatos fossem avaliadas
mais de 2 milhões de vezes de 2 milhões
de veículos
pois bem o processo se para o período
pré-eleitoral que a gente queria era que
as pessoas tivessem consciência de quem
elas realmente estavam votando os
projetos que elas estavam votando no
período pós eleitoral
o que a gente queria aquela que as
propostas do candidato eleito estivessem
disponíveis na internet de forma clara
é claro que a gente sabia que por vezes
o candidato eleito teria que mudar uma
proposta ou outra mas a gente sabia
também da importância de traçar uma
linha e passam de mão de tinta na linha
que separa o excesso de exceção porque a
hora que essa linha desaparecer
de tanto ser cruzada a gente não vai
mais conseguir diferenciar o político
que abre mão dos seus princípios por um
brasil melhor do político que
simplesmente não tem princípio a uma
série de problemas públicos para serem
resolvidos
é uma série de caminhos que convergem
para a solução desses problemas
transparência e participação não serão a
solução para todos os problemas mas
espero ter contribuído para mostrar pra
vocês pelo menos um pouquinho que
transparência e participação pelo menos
muito bom ponto de partida
obrigado